♪ ♪
>> Jesse: JAMES COMEY BACK ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY AFTER TELLING
LAWMAKERS OVER A WEEK AGO WE
DIDN'T KNOW, COULDN'T REMEMBER.
WAS UNABLE TO RECALL A
STAGGERING 245 TIMES.
THE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR VERY
COMBATIVE AFTERWARDS, TAKING
SHOTS OF THE PRESIDENT,
REPUBLICANS, AND FOX NEWS.
>> ANOTHER DAY OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAILS AND THE
STEELE DOSSIER.
THIS, WHILE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, AS LONG ABOUT THE
FBI, ATTACKING THE FBI, AND
ATTACKING THE RULE OF LAW IN
THIS COUNTRY.
AT SOME POINT, SOMEONE HAS TO
STAND UP AND IN THE FACE OF
FOX NEWS, FEAR OF THEIR BASE,
FEAR OF MEAN TWEETS, STAND UP
FOR THE VALLEYS OF THIS COUNTRY
NOT SLINK AWAY INTO RETIREMENT.
THE FBI'S REPUTATION IS TAKING A
BIG HIT BECAUSE OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, WITH HIS
ACOLYTES, HAS LIED ABOUT IT
CONSTANTLY.
A WHOLE LOT OF GOOD PEOPLE WHO
WATCH YOUR NETWORK BELIEVE THAT
NONSENSE.
>> Jesse: I THINK COMEY'S
BOY SCOUT IMAGE, SQUEAKY CLEAN,
NOT FEELING IT.
HE SEEMS CYNICAL AND JADED AND
HYPER PARTISAN.
>> Greg: HE HURT MY FEELINGS.
I'M SAD HE IS SCARED OF ME.
THE FACT IS, THIS IS A CHARADE
OF HONESTY.
HE SAID HE WAS UNABLE TO RECALL
SOMETHING, SOMETHING LIKE 250
TIMES.
BEFORE, HE ALWAYS TALKS ABOUT
HOW IS WILLING TO GO THERE AND
WILLING TO TALK BUT THEN WHEN HE
SITS DOWN, HE SAYS NOTHING.
HE'S LIKE THE GUY WHO SAYS TO
HER, I'LL COME OVER AND HELP YOU
MOVE WITH THEM WHEN HE GETS
THERE, ALL HE DOES IS DRINK THE
BEER AND EAT THE PIZZA YOU PAID
FOR BUT DOESN'T LIFT A FINGER.
HE KEEPS TALKING ABOUT HOW
HONEST HE IS BUT HE DEALS IN
MEETING TWEETS.
HE DEALS IN PLATITUDES.
HE THINKS HE'S A BOY SCOUT BUT
IS MORE LIKE A DISGRUNTLED
PITBULL.
>> Jesse: HE ALSO, JEDEDIAH,
TALKED ABOUT HOW THE PRESIDENT
IS TRYING TO DESTROY THE
REPUTATION OF THE FBI.
THE PRESIDENT FEELS LIKE THE FBI
HAS WRONGED HIM.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF BAD APPLES
AT THE FBI THAT HAVE RESIGNED,
BEEN DEMOTED, GOTTEN IN TROUBLE
FOR LYING AND DOING ALL SORTS OF
REALLY INAPPROPRIATE THINGS.
NOT ALL ON THE PRESIDENT.
THEY HAVE KIND OF DUG THEIR OWN
GRAVE.
>> Jedidiah: THIS IS THE GUY
WHO WITHHELD INFORMATION FROM
THE FISA CORD.
HE'S A JOKE.
HE'S THE ONLY PERSON I'VE SEEN
UP THERE THAT'S LESS
SELF-AWARENESS THAN
HILLARY CLINTON.
HE HAS NO SENSE THAT HE COMES
OFF SO ANTAGONISTIC, TAKES NO
RESPONSIBILITY.
SOMEONE ASKED HIM A QUESTION
ABOUT THE FBI, ABOUT WHETHER HE
FELT AT ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR ITS
REPUTATION GOING SOUTH.
HE CAME FLAT OUT, NO, NOT ME.
IMMEDIATELY SHIFTED BLAME TO THE
PRESIDENT.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IF A PRIVATE CITIZEN WENT INTO
ONE OF THESE FORUMS AND HAD TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS AND GAVE
200 PLUS VERSIONS OF "I DON'T
KNOW" AND "I DON'T RECALL," WHEN
THEY WERE INVOLVED INTO ENORMOUS
CANDLES, THAT WOULDN'T FLY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW HE GETS
AWAY WITH SAYING HE DOESN'T
REMEMBER AND DOESN'T HAVE TO
PROVIDE SOME ANSWERS AS TO WHY
HE WITHHELD ALL THIS INFORMATION
WITH RESPECT TO THE DOSSIER, THE
FACT IT WAS UNVERIFIED, THE FACT
IT WAS FUNDED BY THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN.
NUMEROUS QUESTIONS HE'S ON THE
LINE FOR, ANYTHING IT'S
INTERESTING THAT HE CHOOSES TO
SOUND LIKE HE'S RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
TICKET NOT PROVIDE ADEQUATE
ANSWERS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS.
>> Jesse: I LIKE HOW -- I
DISLIKE HOW HE WENT AFTER
FOX NEWS.
HOW DARE HE GO AFTER THE FIRST
AMENDMENT?
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK ANYONE
AT FOX NEWS WHICH IS --
HERE'S THE THING ABOUT WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE GOING AFTER COMEY.
COMEY IS THE VILLAIN, I GUESS
THAT MEANS TRUMP IS YOUR HERO.
TO ME, COMEY IS ON TARGET WHEN
HE SAYS THEY'VE BEEN GOING AFTER
THE FBI.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIMINISHES THE
FBI BECAUSE HE DOESN'T LIKE WHAT
THEY'VE SAID.
HE ALSO DIMINISHES THE CIA,
DIMINISHES ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T
AGREE WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: YOU JUST LEARNED
THIS?
THAT HE CRITICIZES PEOPLE?
>> Juan: IT USED TO BE THAT
REPUBLICANS STOOD UP FOR LAW AND
ORDER.
THIS IS THE SECOND PART OF WHAT
COMEY DID TODAY, HE SAID THE
ENTIRE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT,
BOTH IN THE SENATE AND THE
HOUSE, HAVE JUST BASICALLY LAY
DOWN FOR TRUMP.
IT'S BECOME NOT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, THE PARTY OF TRUMP.
JIM COMEY SAID YOU NEED TO STAND
UP.
THAT'S WHY HE SAID WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT FOX NEWS.
>> Greg: IF WE HAD MARCO RUBIO
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU WOULD BE
SAYING IT'S THE PARTY OF MARCO
RUBIO.
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA
WOULD'VE SAID HATEFUL THINGS
ABOUT RUBIO.
>> Juan: PRESIDENT BUSH HAD A
TOUGH TIME WITH THE MEDIA AND
FELLOW REPUBLICANS.
NO ONE SAID IT WAS THE PARTY OF
BUSH.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
A REAL PROBLEM WITH THE MEDIA,
RIGHT, JUAN?
SEE.
THERE'S A MOVIE ABOUT
DICK CHENEY THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
RIP HIM TO SHREDS.
BUT THEY DID DIFFICULT --
AS LONG AS YOU ARE.
>> Dana: HIM JUAN MENTIONED,
COMEY MENTIONS THE REPUBLICANS
WHO AREN'T SPEAKING OUT.
WHAT DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL SAID
HILLARY WAS WRONG ABOUT BENGHAZI
WHICH DEMOCRATS CAME OUT AND
SAID HAVING A PRIVATE EMAIL
SERVER WAS WRONG?
YOU DEFEND YOUR TEAM.
YOU ARE ON A TEAM AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT IS.
>> Juan: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE STRUGGLED WITH THE EMAIL
SERVER.
>> Dana: THEY DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING.
THEY ALL SAID IT WAS NO BIG DEA
DEAL.
THE OTHER THING IS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NOMINEES AND
FBI DIRECTOR, CHRISTOPHER WRAY,
YOU NEVER SEE HIM.